foreign
[Music]
the data collected in your Erp systems
is highly valuable for making proactive
decisions and predicting business
outcomes
however these systems are extremely
complex and getting data out of them can
be tedious in addition as critical
business processes depend on the Erp
it's important to maintain the system's
performance while extracting data out in
this video we're sharing a seamless way
to bring your data from sap one of the
most prevalent Erp systems into Google
Cloud to serve as a scalable consistent
single source of Truth bring data
together and keep it highly secure
cloud data Fusion is Google Cloud's
Enterprise grade data integration
service for building data warehouses
data lakes and data Marts on bigquery
data Fusion offers the capability to
seamlessly extract data from sap ECC s
for Hana and business warehouse and
business warehouse for Hana and ingest
it into bigquery Google Cloud's data
warehouse solution with data Fusion
users can Wrangle and prepare sap data
join it with other data from
applications public data sets or
databases and then cleanse and load it
into bigquery
once the data is in bigquery you can
apply artificial intelligence and
machine learning to uncover insights and
activate the data to better understand
customers and react to their needs let's
head into the data Fusion UI on the home
page you'll see the services of data
Fusion including Wrangle where you can
cleanse and transform raw data code free
integrate which allows you to visually
design ETL data Pipelines
replicate where you can set your data to
replicate continuously and in real time
from operational data stores
Discovery and govern where you can
explore data lineage and administrative
services to do monitoring and management
of your Pipelines
to integrate with sap data sources data
Fusion supports four plugins
table batch Source odata ODP and SLT
replication
in this demo environment there are a few
sap data pipelines deployed for a
variety of business use cases
for example
a pipeline that loads materials
requirement planning data to help plan
the material and procurement planning
needs of a business
and another pipeline that loads orders
and purchase data to monitor the status
of purchase order lines
these pipelines are using different
plugins depending on the data ingestion
and extraction use cases
for example you could configure bulk
transfers and extractions using table
batch or odata plugins
Delta transfers using the ODP plugin and
more real-time replication using the SLT
plugin
let's look at one of the example
pipelines in detail this pipeline joins
two sap sales order tables vbap and vbac
using the table batch reader the
projection operation is available to
help map sap schema names into more
business understandable names
you can also perform wrangling on the
data directly within the pipeline
next this join our transformation joins
the records of the two tables and then
the pipeline loads the data into
bigquery
click run to start the pipeline
after the pipeline is completed you can
view the transform data that has been
loaded into bigquery
back in the data Fusion UI you can head
to summary to see statistics about the
pipeline lastly data Fusion also
provides sap accelerators which you can
access by clicking to view the Hub
these accelerators are pre-packaged
templates to make your sap pipeline
deployments much easier
you can filter for specific accelerators
based on your use cases like order to
Cache procure to pay or based on plugins
by leveraging these sap Integrations you
can both improve your developer
productivity and accelerate your time to
Value pipeline Studio allows developers
to read from sap code free and to use
pre-built transformations to speed up
data cleaning and preparation once the
sap data is available in bigquery you
can immediately start building ml models
using bqml or utilize other Advanced
capabilities of the Google Cloud
portfolio to gain business insights to
learn more about the data Fusion sap
plugins check out the documentation
Linked In the description below or reach
out to your sales representative if you
have any questions or would like to
discuss how data Fusion can help your
data Journey
foreign
[Music]